The joe rogan experience.
squarespace.com is the best resource I've ever found online for creating a
really cool looking website very easily.
Any dumdum can do it.
Probably even me.
Brian does them.
Every time we do a fucking podcast,
he'll throw a new one up,
fart@cocc.com the machine,
he's creating a machine website right now as we speak.
Okay.
What does it say?
We're going to just kind of create a fucking website.
It's super easy to use.
You can make online stores very easily.
All of it is very easy and this is all stuff that just simply was not available
just a few years ago,
a few years ago,
if you wanted to get a website done,
you either had to hire someone who really knows how to code and do a website or
master one of those,
uh,
um,
kind of complicated programs for creating websites.
But Squarespace makes it super easy.
I learned html right when it,
right before it got useless.
Ah,
did you learn it?
Like the little thing?
Nobody,
you ref all that.
I learned how to do it and I learned like a few things and then just when they
started saying,
you don't have to do that anymore,
you can just type in the thing.
It'll show up.
It's Kinda dope though.
It's Kinda like,
um,
I mean,
I,
I've never done it myself.
It's Burt,
let's square per.com
that should so be a website squirt.
When he quickly,
quickly Brian registered that squirt burden,
let's squirt burt.com quickly,
quickly go to hover.
You know,
what is,
uh,
a little element?
Yeah.
Society that we too quickly accepted what the,
the people that have a stand that they set up in front of the exit door at the
fucking grocery store,
gay and lesbians,
whatever it is.
And they were like,
take a second for gay and lesbian rights.
The Guy,
the guy,
do you have one minute for gay rights?
Yeah.
He put his finger in my face and I went,
no,
I don't like him.
And he was like,
excuse me?
I go,
I'm kidding.
I don't have time,
man.
And he was like,
well,
hold on Gip.
And now you're like commit a hate crime by just passing them by.
Yeah.
It's guilt.
It's like the guilt stop after you're walking out with your organic vegetables.
Take two seconds to make sure a porn stars wear condoms.
I'm with my kids.
I'm like,
I go,
no thanks.
Did they really say that?
Swear to God outside the target.
Who's second porn stars wear condoms.
Daddy.
What's a condom?
Yup.
I'm with my daughters,
my wife and,
but I sold myself out quick and was like,
no way.
And my website,
excuse me.
And I was like,
who wasn't where common.
It was like,
I don't,
I want them not to have you.
I grew up,
you ever seen a point where they're wearing condoms?
And she was like,
no,
I've never seen a porn.
I go with fucking bomb has never seen a porn.
My wife has never seen a porn.
Wow.
She's potatoes.
Yeah.
Meat,
potatoes.
And she doesn't have to squirt easy with that.
If I didn't shut the fuck both of them.
What a is no consensus on what that squirting stuff is.
Dana D Armand.
Apparently she's changed her position,
but she told me it was pissed.
She saw me.
Those girls a piano on each other and now apparently she does not.
Not,
there's not a gland inside of vagina that produces a liter of fluid too,
so it explodes at the end.
That's not real.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's 100% real.
It's not even like a fucking conspiracy.
Like you said,
talk to red band over here.
You're
100% to a hundred percent proven that it's not pissed.
Look,
I've been,
I've had squirt in my mouth millions of times.
I've been price did it.
I haven't.
Definitely not.
It's definitely not pee.
It's a 100% okay,
here we go.
It's going to work.
I did and I got to the myths.
Here's the myth
about squirting.
Okay,
you're ready.
Myth number one that it's p wow.
Many experts believe that what comes out of a woman,
she's a Jackie planting his urine,
but women who squirt will tell you otherwise.
Some have given it the smell,
even taste test and insist it's not.
P research is determined that the fluid admitted during orgasm showed all the
characteristics of prostate plasma.
What is that?
Don't Bam,
when you don't even know what that is.
Brian.
He's like,
yeah,
prostate plasma kid told you the pilot was on
and not urine and concluded.
This might be proof that our para youth,
real hmm Skeens gland where the fluid comes from,
function as female prostate glands.
Wow.
So apparently the theory is that in,
in some women,
this one gland can also,
it functions almost as like an ejaculate.
I'll tell you,
I'm willing to accept that.
Not I'm willing to accept that possibly there is a minority of women just like
Puffy Nipples,
like puffy nipples or something that not everyone has,
but then you see them and you know what I mean?
I'm pretty sure I could make any girl squirt it to a hundred percent Brian all
throw up.
Yeah,
for sure.
Not that kind of squares.
I be like,
listen,
if this is what it takes to get them out of the bed,
I'll piss in it.
But this is what it says.
Does that mean this website is saying that every woman is capable of doing it.
They just have to learn.
Okay.
So it says there are lots of experts and female sex.
Let me tell you what website this is called,
the Frisky,
the frisky.com and it's six myths about squirting.
If you want to look forward to yourself,
if you're like,
hmm,
I'd like to know more about squirting Joe.
There's actually a video.
It's also online that will teach you how to,
to actually make a girl squirt.
Cause there's two like two main ways to make a girl squirt.
And obviously the easiest one is you know her g spot and if you just hit her g
spot,
like if you're licking the pussy and you have a finger on the g spot the whole
time and your effort,
you can make her score squirt that way.
Or if you just know the right positions to fuck her at your Dick and hit that g
spot and it's really easy to do.
And you could just watch this video and you could make her a square.
It's not,
it's really easy to do.
Yeah.
But I saw a girl squirt when she's getting fucked up or,
but how's that work?
Because that's a different kind of,
uh,
orgasms
is Christ.
That's not the same.
That's not a g spot orgasm.
Brian over here,
that's actually that orgasm that she had is actually a deeper,
harder to get orgasms if you did really see that,
but a lot of important yet.
But a lot of porn actually fakes a squirting import information from as if this
is like hardcore.
I know a lot about squirting,
man.
I want to,
I have water.
I have wired,
I know a lot about squirting.
Dude.
I have waterproof sheets now because it will ruin your warranty on your mattress
if it starts getting girls farting.
That's one position.
Um,
so this is another one.
It's also saying that it's not,
that's a myth that it's caused by the stimulation of the g spot.
Okay.
Every woman is not capable of doing it.
I'm sorry when I said that,
that's actually a myth.
So that's one of the,
that's one of the things that they're saying it's a myth or every woman's
capable then.
Yeah.
Never a woman's not capable.
This is saying in the five myths,
one of them is,
is not p two is that every woman is capable of doing it.
They just have to learn.
She's saying no or he or whoever wrote this look,
ask Jeeves has a different opinion.
It's Amy,
a woman they made,
oh no,
I made her squirt
Ami,
so I guess the dude,
sorry.
Ami when named John.
Amy.
Bro.
I'm sorry.
Um,
regardless,
everything like porn porn,
I've disconnected a tad bit from porn because I missed,
I'll watch it,
but it just seems like a lot of the shit,
the way you've seen a porn just isn't stuff that happens in this website.
Just lost me.
You just said exactly what I was reading,
which is hilarious.
We sure?
Yes,
exactly why you were saying this.
It's at number six.
As far as the myths of porn,
that what you see in porn is real.
The porn is unrealistic sexual expectations and imposes upon us.
We see a large amount of fluid squirting out of a woman's vagina and porn.
Keep in mind,
this could be faked by putting water on her vagina before filming or having a
woman p on camera who can ejaculate will tell you that it's easiest when you're
relaxed and having cameras on you is not the most relaxing when experience
pleasure.
I've talked about my free cams before.
That's the biggest thing right now the other girls are doing is they have these
dildos that actually have water in it,
the water in you,
and then they explode and so every girl's squirting right now.
Looks like so may,
so there you go.
While you were saying that,
while you were saying that,
I was reading it.
Serendipity.
It's crazy,
man.
It's like you and I are like connected man.
In this
journey.
I feel like we already are Chemo Wasabi.
It's like the new ad for the lone ranger with Johnny Depp.
That's what I feel like.
Dude.
Fucking hungry.
Squirt Burt.
Dot.
Dotcoms live Joe squared per second.
This whole fucking time when I got out,
Joe,
I can't show it up close.
I have to shut this version of you just play.
It doesn't do anything.
Oh Geez.
Oh No,
you've been doing this whole fucking so do something now.
That one right there,
background,
that girl's pissing on that dude.
Yeah.
This is me.
That's be a fake one at Burt's.
Doing.
Oh,
that one was actually real.
Yeah.
He came the hardest ever.
Oh my God.
Hey,
will you put my tour dates up one?
Cause I know a million people visit that
freaky.